people in Hawaii are keeping a close eye
on news about North Korea this morning
the Pentagon reportedly detected signs
the country could carry another missile
test today
North Korea's last intercontinental
ballistic missile test earlier this
month raised global concerns some
experts believe the missile had the
range to reach Alaska and Hawaii Hawaii
is the first state to announce a public
campaign urging people to prepare for a
nuclear attack Carter Evans is in
Honolulu in a cold war-era tunnel deep
under the dominate volcanic crater we're
in a bunker underneath about a hundred
feet of rock these Seoul military
tunnels are now used for storage but one
lawmaker here in Hawaii would like to
change that you see this could be an
ideal place to ride out a nuclear attack
if only there were enough time to get
here every time North Korea fires a
missile the regime gets one step closer
to reaching the Hawaiian Islands in the
last two years there was 56 missile
launches you've been paying attention
that is a wake-up thought State
Representative Jean Ward says it would
take less than 20 minutes for a nuclear
missile to reach Honolulu something
state officials want the nearly one and
a half million people who live in the
islands to prepare for first thing that
we are responsible for is the security
of our people so you're looking at what
you got insane we got something we could
put to use here at least to keep the
government running and that's the
important part of it in the event of a
nuclear emergency Ward wants key
government officials to have a safe
place to operate here beneath Diamond
Head the jewel of Waikiki houses a
little-known network of tunnels the
military has used for more than a
century this is something that public
doesn't get to see very well Lieutenant
Colonel Charles Anthony is with the
National Guard he showed us the
labyrinth of concrete tunnels and
bunkers built into the dormant volcano
and he says there are no plans to use
them as a shelter so this was never
designed
people for any period of time no it was
designed to withstand an artillery
barrage and also to unleash an artillery
barrage in the opposite direction but
this was not really designed for people
this is designed for equipment material
and weapons back in the 50s the
government turned these old ammunition
storage rooms in the tunnels into a
civil defense hub today the state's
Emergency Operations Center runs 24/7 in
an underground bunker nearby we'll have
about 15 minutes or so to get the world
retired general Vernie ah he is in
charge of the state's Emergency
Management Agency he says don't expect
those 50s era civil defense drills first
you duck and then you'll cover emergency
officials believe the majority of the
population here would survive the
initial explosion what they need to be
prepared for is the nuclear fallout and
to stay inside for up to two weeks what
we focus on right now is shelter in
place now ideas to figure out ahead of
time where you are when your family is
and what is the best type of shelter
that they could get to at that time of
the day what a lot of people are
concerned about here on the islands is
the impact that all this talk about a
nuclear attack could have on tourism you
see this economy relies heavily on the
roughly nine million visitors who come
here every year and the local government
wants everyone to know Hawaii is still
open for business that is a good message
but it's very unsettling that you even
have to consider this exactly more
people to talk about sort of yeah the
idea of what's going to happen that's
right yeah well they're making the
preparations and doing what's right you
know where Carter Evans in Hawaii we
thank you sir